[Music]
inventor author and futurist Ray
Kurzweil live on in-depth the Sunday
beginning at noon eastern on book TV
world renowned inventor of
computer-based musical instruments and
author of several books on artificial
intelligence including the age of
intelligent machines the singularity is
near and is bestseller the age of
spiritual machines join our live
three-hour discussion as book TVs in
depth welcomes Ray Kurzweil this Sunday
at noon eastern on c-span - this is the
11th annual Texas Book Festival Laura
Bush the first lady was the first lady
of Texas when she started this and now
she is the honorary chairman the book TV
bus is in Austin for this festival and
we're in the book TV bus with Matthew
Continent he is the author of this book
the K Street gang the rise and fall of
the Republican machine you are in the
home state of one of the major players
of your book Tom DeLay absolutely what
is his role in this book Tom DeLay the
machine politician who came to Congress
as part of the Texas six-pack 1984 and
then did so much to create the K Street
project which was the shifting of the
lobbyist community's alliance from the
Democratic Party to the Republican Party
after the Republican revolution in 1994
you have some other people it's pictures
on the front of your book that are also
a part of that who are they well there's
of course Jack Abramoff at the center of
a wide-ranging lobbying and corruption
scandal Abramoff of course pleaded
guilty earlier this year to bribing
public officials also on the cover is
Ralph Reed the former executive director
of the Christian Coalition who because
of his ties David moth recently lost a
primary for lieutenant governor in
Georgia last July and the final member
of the gang on the cover is Grover
Norquist the anti-tax activist a
longtime ally of Abramoff and Norquist
Abramoff and reads whose group Americans
for Tax Reform was used as a path pass
through a kind of shell for which
Abramoff could funnel money
from his Indio casino clients to Ralph
Reed's consulting business is this an
anti Republican book I wouldn't say so
I'm a conservative it's written from a
conservative perspective it's written
more in sorrow than in anger it's a book
about how idealists came to power and
then found themselves corrupted by it
found themselves coming to Washington do
good and then staying there to do well
so I would have say it's the anti
Republican book it's certainly attacks
certain members of the Republican Party
and that's because I think it's
important for conservatives to recognize
that we do have some bad actors in the
movement what it was your own story and
getting to this book sure well I came to
Washington relatively recently from
school in New York City and then worked
at the Weekly Standard and when the
Abramoff scandal broke we've we've
thought at the Weekly Standard that this
was definitely important not only to
cover as a story in itself because the
tale of corruption is so interesting
it's almost novelistic and sometimes
it's reads like parody but also as
conservatives it was important to
recognize this to say that we are able
to confront the bad facts and move
beyond them and so that's how we came to
I came to write the K Street gang what's
gonna happen if that doesn't happen
what's gonna happen to the party
oh absolutely well we look at a
situation now heading into the midterm
election where I think all too many
parts of the party certainly a house and
the Republican majority in the house
have not been able to confront these
facts Tom DeLay resigned from Congress
resigned from his position as Majority
Leader but then the person who replaced
him
Blount or was in race to replace and
then Boehner actually replaced him from
Ohio Boehner of course before he became
Majority Leader
famous for actually taking checks from
tobacco lobbies here at the on the House
floor so all of these people in the
leadership have ties I think to close
ties to the business community in the
lobbying community and I was actually
thinking longer-term what are we talking
about for the presidential election but
even further out than that well what do
Republicans need to do to get their
hands around well the problem that you
outline in the book well some of the
works already been done for them you
know it's always kind of heartening for
me to find out that actually most of the
members of the K Street gang have either
been arrested
they're on their way to jail or they've
been forced out of politics entirely the
gang has basically been broken up and so
I think that's a reassuring sign a
longer term I think we're going to find
that the conservative movement is going
to look inward certainly after the 2006
election and into the 2008 presidential
election it's not it's going to be less
concerned I think about expanding its
majorities and of course the majorities
are endangered but also more concerned
about revitalizing its ideas because I
think we've seen and I think stories
like this show that conservatism is it's
a tired movement it's a it's powers that
are waning and I think it's time that
the Conservatives are going to go look
back and see how to write revitalizing
what kind of conservative are you I
consider myself a new conservative as
someone who's a little bit uh you know
less concerned with the size of
government but also thinks that there's
a role for government to play and I have
a kind of limited government though
however you know you don't want an over
a overweening government and also
someone who believes in championing
democracy throughout the world and your
position on the war in Iraq I'm a
supporter of the war in Iraq why well I
felt that at the time obviously the
threat that Saddam Hussein posed to the
region and to the United States was real
and since we find ourselves doing our
best to support very fragile government
there against radicals on both the Sunni
extremist side and the Shia radical side
and then of course al-qaeda is in Iraq
as well so I think we need to continue
to prosecute the war there certainly do
much more to achieve victory there which
is not the case now this the story in
this book was covered extensively in the
newspapers hi how much original
reporting did you do for this book I did
interviews with conservative movement
officials a lot of this book involved
research more into the story itself of
course talking with the investigators in
the Senate Indian Affairs Committee who
were also investigating this story as as
I was writing it but of course it does
rely heavily on the Pulitzer
prize-winning reportage of a Susan
Schmidt and James Grimaldi of the
Washington Post who did a stunning work
on the story
and what was there a time when writing
this book that you said I can't believe
they did that
I think the one moment where that really
came to me that kind of realization is
this is just an amazing story it
concerns the Tigua try but they'll pass
up here in Texas and this was a tribe
that Abramoff and his gang basically
helped to close down a casino but then
without the tribes knowledge they then
went to the casino did the tribe and
said well we'll help you reopen it and
so there's just kind of the stunning
hubris agreed that you'd find that
characterizes so many of Abramov's
exploits were you able to interview any
of the major players of you know I
wasn't
did you try I did speak to ralph reed
but and grover norquist briefly but not
Abramoff nor Scanlon do ralph reed and
grover norquist have a future in the
republican party hierarchy i believe
they do
I believe Ralph Reed said career has
been damaged by the same law scandal I
don't believe he's down and out he was
recently in Washington for example
celebrating the 10th anniversary of the
National Review Online Grover Norquist
of course though I believe embarrassed
by the scandal continues to have power
in Washington the question is who is the
next generation of conservative leaders
who will come to power and whether they
will rely on read and Norquist as
certain elements in the Bush
administration in the house leadership
half that that's an open question and it
may not be to their liking it's a couple
examples of people that might be who are
you look at if you look an outside group
say if you have someone like Mitt Romney
say become president United States
he's from outside Washington he's not
necessarily going to look inside the
Washington conservative movement
community for leadership now of course
John McCain to who has a very public
grievances with Norquist agreed if he
were to ascend in the Republican Party
ranks I believe there they would wave
their power would wane and who's going
to make that decision of who's going to
rise well it's the voters and that's why
I great about American democracy is
ultimately we do get the government that
represents us for bed
worth so a conservative activists of
course in those primary states but we're
seeing a heavy influx of independent
spending from political party groups in
this election will that influence
continue in future elections Oh
certainly I don't think money is leaving
politics any time soon and of course the
great thing about the rules that are
perhaps the upsetting thing about the
rules if you reformer is that they're
always ways around them they certainly
in politics and we find that every time
people try to address the issue of money
in politics they construct this
elaborate campaign finance machinery
people find ways to circumvent it you
know there's a quote from Ralph read in
the book that says he said once that
money is like water it's gonna find a
way to go around the trees and that's
certainly the case every new time we
tried to ban soft money for example we
didn't have these 527 groups to sprout
up out of nowhere so I think rather than
to try to prevent money in politics we
may need to just expand the arena and
have more room for him to recognize that
money's gonna play a role but then focus
more on issues and debate where are you
from originally I'm from Northern
Virginia from Burke Virginia right
outside Washington DC and which
politicians influenced you as you were
growing up well there's no question Newt
Gingrich did as I was growing up then
Newt Gingrich